seit rund anderthalb jahrhunderten
nutzen wir elektrischen strom
heute braucht ihn jeder smartphone
fernseher elektroauto kein wunder dass
der weltweite bedarf laut berechnungen
der internationalen energieagentur
kontinuierlich steigt bekannte
energiequellen wie öl und kohle werden
wegen ihrer umweltschädlichkeit immer
unbeliebter und gehen auch irgendwann
zur neige atomkraft produziert atommüll
dennoch in tausenden von jahren
gefährliche strahlung abgibt
neben erneuerbaren energien forschen
wissenschaftler aus aller welt deshalb
an anderen lösungen um unseren hunger
nach immer mehr energie zu stellen
eine lösung strich durch ihre eleganz
hervor die kernfusion
mit ihr könnten wir den menschheitstraum
von unendlicher sauberer energie wahr
werden lassen
aber wie funktioniert kernfusion
eigentlich und wann kommt das erste mal
fusion strom aus unserer steckdose
[Musik]
dieses video ist teil einer
kollaboration mit den jungs von
simplicissimus auf ihrem kanal geht es
darum wie die kernfusion unsere welt
revolutionieren könnte der link zu ihrem
video ist der allererste unten in der
video beschreibung das vorbild für die
kernfusion kennen und nutzen wir alle
jeden tag die sonne seit millionen von
jahren streit unsere sonne energie in
form von licht ab diese energie kommt
durch die fusion von wasserstoff im
inneren 99,8 der masse unseres
sonnensystems sind in der sonne vereint
und es ist diese masse die den nötigen
druck und die temperatur erzeugt um
atomkerne miteinander zu verschmelzen
jede sekunde fusionieren im inneren der
sonne 564 millionen tonnen wasserstoff
zu helium um die gleiche energie zu
produzieren müssten alle atomkraftwerke
auf der erde
750.000 jahre lang laufen unsere sonne
ist also ein gigantischer fusionsreaktor
aber was passiert eigentlich bei einer
kernfusion
wie ihr vielleicht wisst besteht ein
atomkern aus protonen mit positiver
ladung und neutronen mit neutraler
ladung
beide werden auch luke leone genannt und
wirken anziehend aufeinander wenn sie
sich auf wenige kern radien annähern
da ein atomkern aber im gesamten positiv
geladen ist stoßen sich zwei atomkerne
natürlicher weise voneinander ab die
dabei wirkenden kraft wird kohlekraft
genannt und sie wird größer je kleiner
der abstand zwischen den kernen wird
innerhalb eines atomkerns herrschen aber
auch einige andere spannende kräfte
sieht man zum beispiel ein helium atom
so fällt einem auf dass dieses weniger
wiegt als die gesamtmasse seiner
einzelnen klee ohne wie kann das sein
nun das phänomen trägt den namen massen
defekt und wird durch einsteins
berühmter formel gleich m c quadrat
erklärt zur erinnerung die masse eines
systems blatt proportional zu seiner
energie und zwar um den faktor c-quadrat
also lichtgeschwindigkeit zum quadrat
nach einstein wurde die differenz der
masse also in energie umgewandelt
man spricht von bindungsenergie also die
energie aufgewendet werden muss um einen
atomkern in seinen look leone zu
verlegen
und genau das ist der punkt der für uns
spannend ist werden umgekehrt bedeutet
das auch dass dieselbe menge an energie
frei wird wenn sich millionen zu einem
kern vereinigen
eine fusion gibt also energie frei wenn
das neue element eine geringere masse
als die ursprünglichen kerne hat
da die masse in energie umgewandelt und
freigesetzt wurde
und genau diese energie wollen wir in
einem kernfusionsreaktor nutzen
okay wir müssen also nur atomkerne
miteinander verschmelzen und schon
kriegen wir energie ja leichter gesagt
als getan um eine kernfusion zu erzielen
müssen die kerne mit einer ausreichenden
geschwindigkeit aufeinanderprallen die
geschwindigkeit von teilchen ist das was
wir als temperatur wahrnehmen je höher
die temperatur ist desto höher ist die
geschwindigkeit mit der die teilchen
aufeinander treffen und dass diese
geschwindigkeit hoch genug dann kann es
zu einer fusion kommen
wichtig ist aber auch die dichte je mehr
teilchen pro volumen zu finden sind
desto wahrscheinlicher ist es dass zwei
umherfliegende teilchen zusammengestoßen
eine höhere dichte führt also zu mehr
fusions reaktionen weil im inneren der
sonne ein unvorstellbar großer druck von
250 milliarden bar herrscht kann sie mit
einer vergleichsweise kühlen temperatur
von 15,6 millionen kelvin kerne
fusionieren
hier auf der erde haben dass unsere
wissenschaftler leider nicht ganz so
leicht da wir nur wenig druck aufbauen
können müssen wir eine extrem hohe
temperatur von mindestens 100 bis 150
millionen kelvin erreichen
das ist heiß genug um die cologne kraft
zu überwinden aber auch wirklich einen
trick den quantenmechanischen
tunneleffekt der würde an dieser stelle
etwas zu weit führen wenn ihr euch mehr
für die welt der quanten interessiert
dann habe ich euch hier eine kleine
serie von mir zu diesem thema verlinkt
aber zurück zum thema wenn es unter
diesen bedingungen also 100 bis 150
millionen kelvin zu einer kernfusion
kommt erhalten wir unsere neuen atom
klaren und ein freies neutron
und in der geschwindigkeit dieses
neutrons steckt jetzt ein großer teil
der frei gewordenen energie
[Musik]
bei diesen temperaturen wird materie zu
plasma plasma entsteht hier auf der erde
zum beispiel den blitzen oder in
polarlichter es ist einfach gesagt ein
ionisiertes gas und lässt sich schwer
isolieren
auf der sonne wird das plasma durch die
gravitation seiner schieren masse
zusammengehalten
hier auf der erde funktioniert das
leider nicht einschließen kann man es
auch nichts dass von den winden des
behälters zu schnell abgekühlt werden
würde
deswegen behelfen wir uns mit einem
trick der plasma im wesentlichen aus
protonen und elektronen also geladenen
teilchen besteht kann man es mit hilfe
von magnetfeldern manipulieren
die idee ist also ein vakuum zu kreieren
indem man das plasma mit hilfe von
magneten schweben lässt
dazu bieten sich mehrere möglichkeiten
zwei davon stechen durch ihre effizienz
aber besonders hervor
und die heißen talker mack und
stellarator in beiden fällen wird mit
hilfe von spulen einen tourbus förmiges
magnetfeld erzeugt indem sich das plasma
bewegt dass sie dann ein bisschen aus
wie ein donut oder ein autoreifen die
magnetfeldlinien können nun aber nicht
einfach einen kreis bilden diese form
wäre instabil
stattdessen muss das magnetfeld
verdrillt werden beim töpfermarkt sieht
man das indem man das plasma mit strom
induziert
dieser strom sorgt nicht nur dafür dass
das plasma auf seiner bahn bleibt
sondern erhitzt es dabei auch noch ein
positiver nebeneffekt beim stellarator
wird das magnetfeld des donuts nur durch
die äußeren spulen verzerrt das hier ist
eine animation des magnetfeldes im
wendelstein 7-x in greifswald den ich
übrigens auch besucht habe durch seine
besondere bauweise kann der stellarator
auf den teilchen anschluss abgestimmt
werden und prinzipiell im dauerbetrieb
arbeiten
gleiches ist beim talker mag wenn
überhaupt nur mit hohem aufwand möglich
wie genau die einzelnen spuren geformt
sind ist extrem komplex und konnte erst
mit dem aufkommen von supercomputern
berechnet werden
der zuckermarkt wurde früher besser
erforscht und ist deswegen heute schon
näher an der praktischen anwendung der
stelle radtour muss sich erst noch
beweisen hat aber eindeutige vorteile
wie zb dass er ständig laufen kann und
dass er stabiler ist
[Musik]
eine einfache kernfusion ist kein
hexenwerk schon so mancher hobby tüftler
hat in seiner garage kerne fusioniert
der trick liegt aber darin mehr energie
kontrolliert aus dem system heraus zu
holen als man hinein steckt und das ist
aktuell noch das große hindernis die
energiegewinnung selber klingt am ende
übrigens relativ banal das neutron dass
bei einer fusion entsteht wird in den
wänden des reaktors abgebremst dort
erzeugte wärme die dann wasser erhitzt
und der dampf dieses wassers treibt
turbinen an die strom erzeugen können
in einem möglichen kommerziellen
fusionsreaktor könnte man zehnmal mehr
energie herausholen als man hinein
stecken muss um die fusion aufrecht zu
erhalten
die rohstoffe dafür sind einfach zu
finden dort helium lässt sich beinahe
unerschöpflich meerwasser finden und
tritium ließe sich innerhalb des
kraftwerks aus lithium gewinnen
ein kilogramm wasserstoff würde die
gleiche menge an energie freisetzen die
bei der verbrennung von 11.000 tonnen
kohle entsteht
kernfusion wäre also wirklich eine
praktisch unbegrenzte form der
energieerzeugung
dennoch gibt es ein paar
gesundheitsbedenken lithium ist
gesundheitsschädlich und kann bei
mangelnder vorsicht austreten und ganz
strahlungsfreie ist kernfusion auch
nicht ähnlich wie bei der kernspaltung
entsteht atommüll nur ist der
unterschied dass dieser eine deutlich
geringere halbwertszeit besitzt fusions
atommüll wäre also nicht auf ewig unter
der erde sondern nur für ein paar
jahrzehnte bis man ihn gefahrlos
recyceln kann
das größte manko an der herkömmlichen
atomkraft der supergau kann bei
fusionskraftwerken gar nicht passieren
wenn etwas schiefgeht kühlt das plasma
sofort ab sicherheits und
umwelteigenschaften eines
fusionskraftwerk sind also ungemein
günstiger als die eines kern oder
kohlekraftwerks
also wenn alles so perfekt ist wo
bleiben dann die fusionskraftwerke hier
wird es ein bisschen politisch und dafür
habe ich mir die jungs von
simplizissimus eingeladen
hi in der realität wird es
wahrscheinlich noch mindestens 30 jahre
dauern bis es wirklich rentable
fusionskraftwerke gibt tatsächlich waren
fusionskraftwerke irgendwie schon immer
30 jahre entfernt die idee ist
eigentlich uralt und schon in den 50ern
gab es erste experimente in amerika
europa und der sowjetunion eine
internationale kooperation kam aber nur
schleichend in die gänge und erst 1991
wurde in england zum ersten mal
kontrolliert fusionsenergie freigesetzt
auch beim geld hat es lange gehabt hat
die anlage etat soll als demo
fusionskraftwerk fungieren und ihr bau
wurde in den 80ern beschlossen mit
diesem bau wurde erst 20 jahre später
begonnen unser energieproblem und der
klimawandel wurden lange nicht ernst
genug genommen und waren nicht greifbar
genug niemand hatte ausreichendes
interesse daran fusionsenergie ernsthaft
voranzutreiben
außerdem ist das unterfangen natürlich
wahnsinnig komplex praktikable
fusionsenergie gilt als eine der größten
wissenschaftlichen und ingenieurs
technischen herausforderungen der
menschheit
warum fusionsenergie aber trotzdem
zukunftsweisend ist und deutschland und
die welt verändern könnte das erfahrt
ihr auf dem kanal von simplizissimus die
jungs machen wirklich sehr neiße videos
wenn ihr schon da sein sollte den kanal
auch direkt abonniert
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauern
bleibt neugierig war said
[Musik]